a house of representatives may finally
vote this morning on two of the
president's other priorities a giant
infrastructure package and a larger
social spending bill covering everything
from child care to climate change
democrats have been working on these
measures of course for months now and
our nicole killion is on capitol hill
where she's been tracking it all nicole
good morning
good morning to you tony president biden
has really been working the phones to
try to get his agenda over the finish
line cbs news has learned that he has
made a variety of calls to members to
try to get them to vote yes his 1.75
trillion dollar plan includes universal
pre-k an extension of the child care tax
credit plus tax credits and investments
in clean energy health care and
affordable housing democrats also
included four weeks of paid leave in the
bill and reforms to lower the cost of
some prescription drugs lawmakers worked
late into the night to work out
differences on immigration and some of
the tax provisions and keep in mind that
this bill still has to go through the
senate where moderate democrat joe
manchin has expressed concern about some
of the measures in addition to the
broader spending package house democrats
also plan to vote on a separate trillion
dollar infrastructure bill that's been
on hold for weeks keep in mind they are
really up against the clock especially
after republican victories this week in
virginia and the tight race in new
jersey the pressure is on plus congress
is out next week gail
a lot of people feeling pressure thank
you very much nicole